you're making out for an hour on the
Real Housewives of New York season
finale LuAnn was told her fiance Tom had
kissed another woman just days after he
proposed oh it was awful I felt like
somebody just ripped apart my world
LuAnn ultimately forgave him and the two
are still engaged today
so why forgive well I spoke with LuAnn
exclusively at her home in the Hamptons
Tom and I have dealt with it and it was
a major hiccup in our relationship and
but we've worked through it and we've
become even stronger and we're moving
forward did it make you question
anything in of course after talking to
him and him being completely merciful
for what happened and and I know it
didn't mean anything to him and it was
just a kiss it was somebody that he's
known for a long time and I think people
give up too easy these days and we love
each other so I know that it didn't mean
anything to him and and he felt terrible
and so we worked through it it hasn't
been easy but we worked through it and
we're gonna get married on his birthday
how do you work through it and move
forward what was the key well I think
the key is is to know and believe that
someone is truly remorseful that
somebody truly made a mistake
that there was no premeditation I think
it was not premeditated I think it was a
silly move and and something that he
feels really terrible about so today do
you trust him totally I do I'm gonna
throw you off the side of the boat shut
your mouth do you understand me
any regrets from this season I don't
really have regrets I think that things
happen in life for a reason there's a
reason why your rear view mirror is
smaller than the windshield because I'm
looking forward not behind me and what
about wedding plans what's in the works
right now oh my god I'm so excited I'm
planning we're planning our wedding I'm
looking at wedding dresses right now so
super excited and
putting together the invitations to be
sent out and still finalizing the guest
list so it's a very exciting time